un départ matinal pour les 151
professionnelle mais leur n'a pas
refroidi les supporters et les coureurs
ce dimanche 1er juillet pour l'équipe
pas pour un personnellement mais pour
toute l'équipe fdj pour qu'on garde le
maillot on sent qu'on si on s'y prépare
voilà allez dans la tête c'est fait on
le sait depuis quelques mois que ça sera
de bonheur donc voilà on s'est habitué
où on en est on est on s'y préparer en
amont on a essayé de ses voeux un peu
plus tôt que d'habitude les jours
précédents le natif de versailles couru
quasiment à domicile sur ses routes
d'entraînement dans le public du soutien
celui de ses proches
on les appelle à 25 km d'ici donc on est
devenu amis famille pur produit pour
bien l'encourager au départ de 253 km
quelques uns des meilleurs du peloton
français
le moral est très bon la forme est bonne
c'est beau gâteau de pointe évidemment
en ligne de mire
le championnat est dans l'atelier sont
la route du tour là et c'est sûr que non
on espère le garder dans la pratique
gens motivés à quelques jours du départ
du tour de france voilà notre départ du
championnat de france est toujours un
cours spécial donc je suis content
d'être ici par mantes la jolie a vu
gagner anthony roux de l'équipe groupama
fdj les coureurs sont maintenant tournés
vers le tour de france départ le 7
juillet de vendée